um sorry oh my god I'm overheard
everyone thank you it's the beginning
yes hello welcome back to hey [ __ ]
oh hi hope you were ready for that intro
that extremely sexy - what do you got
for us Nikki okay so today we are
talking about finance and I know that's
a pretty broad topic but we wanted to
just talk about the basics stuff that we
wish we would have learned in school
maybe stuff that we wish maybe someone
would have taught us we are not experts
okay
most of us anything else have a master's
but you know this is the only skill not
an X she's probably these financial
information from this podcast just take
it in stride think about it consider it
and then Google and then yeah yeah but
before you move on into that
yeah talking who's doing what oh yeah
let's introduce ourselves I'm Nikki lemo
i am jo kwon since we're doing first and
last night yeah oh then I'm okay who are
you today Jessica or Jess well we're
doing finance oh so yeah actually oh
whoa no she's she's Jessica when she's
feisty
oh I would have thought the opposite cuz
it's so formal like yeah I'm Nicole when
I'm a [ __ ] or whatever no you're just a
[ __ ] when you're a baby that's true
that's true very good point
so we're just gonna go over basics like
not we're not gonna get a heavy into
anything but let's just cover a few
things that would be really helpful if
you're if you're just completely
clueless you're like I just got a job I
just started making money I have no idea
what to do with it or maybe you've been
making money awhile and you just feel
like you're living paycheck to paycheck
and you never know how to manage it well
and you just could really use a leg up
so I think if I were to start I would
start with savings what do you think
that's what everyone wants to know yeah
like how do you say like how do you
actually save and that's something I
want to know - this is a psychological
topic it is because people cannot for
the life of them live under their means
mm-hmm so it's very cycle or do you get
this data from personal experience okay
okay we are a society that thrives off
consumerism I feel like it's shoved in
our faces all the time I mean there are
whole careers of influencers that are
there to like sell you stuff and tell
you all this I wanna get give us some
time we're gonna sell you some stuff
later by some native so for me dude I
love that brand I can't wait to talk
about it later but no for me I was
actually pretty fortunate when I was
growing up for as far back as I can
remember my mom always had this joint
savings with me so she was always like
oh cool yeah it was really really cool
cuz every month she would put in 20
bucks and now in retrospect I'm like 20
bucks so she saved her money for you
yeah but as a little kid I was started
understanding the concept of it and when
I wanted something I was just like oh
why don't I just get money out of my
savings she's like okay but you have
this much and it cost this much once you
take it out like there's not so she
taught you money management really early
yeah yeah even real that's really
awesome cuz I have somewhat of a similar
thing but instead it was a counter
instead it was a savings account that I
never had any access to so here's the
thing Wow it exists that's the thing I
don't think it did so my parents told me
my parents I had a savings account and
that one day it was gonna go towards my
college and then I was like oh that's
cool but then we went through really
hard Financial Times and so I remember
telling my mom like why don't you just
take it out of the savings that you have
for me like you know because she would
always complain like oh my credit so bad
and that's how I knew that we were broke
cuz it was always connected to her
credit and so I was like yeah just take
it out of my savings it's okay like I'll
I'll work and I could pay for my own
college and she would tell me like yeah
you know I've been taking out our
savings yeah you don't have any more
savings left and I'm like did I ever
even have savings like I don't even know
if there would that account ever it
probably had like a hundred bucks in it
for like two weeks and it was like I
can't deal with it I need the money
ya know I don't know I was told a lot
from when I was a kid too because
apparently there was a house in ntj
under my name and then they sold it and
then they were like oh this money is
gonna go for you but I never saw a penny
so I don't know wow you just got really
damaged right so you don't trust a lot
of people I really know
girl that you've learned like money is
told it's there and then it's not there
that's pretty much my whole yeah cuz
girl let me tell you about my
quinceanera - I was gonna have a kid
thing yeah the Mexican sweet 16 for
those of you not mixing yeah and so they
told me like my I didn't even want one
and then we went to go look at the hall
to go check out like the location
through the whole thing my mom came
because I'm her only daughter so she was
like hey you know I'm never gonna get a
chance to have a kid again for my kids
because she has like three other boys
and so I was like but I don't want one I
just want to travel she's like no no
please let me do this for you so we
ended up going through the whole process
I even she wanted me to have two dresses
like she wanted like everything crazy
big and I was just like no and then
finally I got excited we went to the
hall she gave a down payment and the
next thing I know Oh actually we're
gonna buy a house instead of doing your
party so I'm like you know what it
sounds like it sounds like you need to
give this podcast to your mom cuz she
has issues money too you know anything
exactly hi mom shout-out sook she
actually listens to this podcast - oh
yeah so Nicki why'd you say that these
experiences are actually really good
because I do agree with Jess that it is
psychological and in fact the reason a
lot of people are so poor at money
management is because they're scared of
like learning they have really bad
relationships with money and these are
formed by your beliefs in childhood so
if you've always learned that your
relationship with money is you're told
it's there and then it's not your fears
and scares yeah he believes about money
lots of money a lot more and don't do I
actually do yeah that kind of stuff and
then for yugioh since you were taught
like how to manage money I didn't know
how to manage that at all dude rate
really baby you got it like some health
it sounds like you got some healthy
exercises and yeah can I go to people
with zero like zero idea of like having
a piggy shoe savings account as a child
yeah well all I knew was his concept of
a savings account I didn't understand
what it did how I mean I just knew it
was there because you're saving it yeah
but there was never really a goal for it
there was never a real explanation of
like you want to have this in case of a
rainy day or whatever
it was more like I have this for you to
hook you up but I didn't there was like
no time you ever had an allowance no no
oh wow yeah I did so I don't know my my
dad is a CPA and my mom is was a vice
president of a bank so they tell me
about money Laird really early on I
still managed to screw it up because you
make mistakes during life you learn is
growing up so growing up it was similar
to you I did have a savings account but
they never put anything into that I was
working as a model when I was eight
years old and I was cuckoo yeah but that
was before jackie coogan so back then
parents could screw over kids a lot and
that's why those laws were enacted but
at my time it hadn't been enacted yet my
parents were just really generous and
now looking back I see that but they
would take time out of their workday and
drive me to these shoots and I was also
doing extra work and featured work like
I was on Power Rangers and I was like on
the is this movie called the pest with
John Leguizamo and stuff and so it was
it was really cool and that started when
I was eight years old to 12 years old
and so all of the money that I made from
those jobs went into my own account with
my own name on it and I had a savings
like an ATM card that connected to the
savings account and you knew with that
with all four yeah they were basically
like this is your money you can use it
however you want
they didn't train me too much until
later on how to manage money but I just
remember if I wanted to buy a present
for my friend I would pull from my
savings account and I would buy a
present with my own money that I made
from working and I know that I always
wanted a job because I liked being able
to make my own money and that ownership
of it being my money and not having
anyone control what I could or couldn't
buy with my own money so I did learn
money management from spending too much
and then having zero to take out from
until I made my next job crazy but I I
didn't you know have someone telling me
you can or can't spend money oh damn
that's really good yeah but it but if I
ran out of money and I went to my
parents and was like hey can I borrow
money cuz where's your money bro my dad
actually taught me about interest so he
goes yeah
give you this $5.00 but when you make $5
back you have to pay me 525 so you have
to pay me $5 back that's a harder dude
yeah and he always taught me to pay back
with interest because that's that ended
up being how it is in real life credit
cards always have you pay back with
interest and so to this day whenever he
borrows money from me like if he borrows
$10 from me he'll pay me $11 back Oh
cute yeah yeah and so I little things
like that that I didn't realize we're
helpful growing up I thought everybody
got them they actually are super helpful
to my relationship with money and how
how I was able to like always be on
guard on you know like when we were
running low or like when we had to save
that being said savings I know is really
tough on people the biggest help I've
ever gotten and I believe I didn't
really even incorporate this into my
life until I read the book Rich Dad Poor
Dad which I highly suggest everybody
read it's by Robert Kiyosaki he really
teaches you the different ways people
have used their money and how you can
use money to leverage it for you
but is putting away 15% right away so no
matter if you're working as an employee
or if you're a freelancer or if you're
working owning businesses or making
money off investments or whatever put
away 15% of whatever you're making right
off the bat as if it never existed and
when you when you start to build that
pile and forget about it even being
there because if you think about it
taxes are taken out right away
immediately if you're an employee and
you pretend that that was never your
money will usually do the same for
yourself so it's the idea of paying
yourself first so you put away 15%
that's to yourself first and then you
pay the taxes that would have never
worked on me in college really yeah cuz
like so so you also got to think about
like the average person they already
don't understand how percentages work
yeah
so if you told me at 20 something or I
didn't put 15 percent away of whatever
I'm like um I don't I don't even know
what that means like to put fifteen
percent away and then I would be like
but I really want that one thing right
now like I had zero self control and I
just wanted what I wanted immediately
yeah that's true
um so what ended up helping me when I
got older after I [ __ ] up a lot yeah
it was like okay well let me just set a
goal so I want to travel yeah so then I
say okay so I'm gonna make this account
that so happens to be a savings account
I'm gonna title it my travel account and
then I would put away like a hundred
bucks if if I could that was like my
goal to put away a hundred bucks every
month and be like okay this is going
towards my travel dad it was so helpful
I would kind of see that like I would
just use whole numbers yeah having a
goal in mind like cuz it is like it is
all psychological it's like why would I
just put this money aside for whatever
reason we're like I'm gonna spend it
because I want something you're having
that goal in mind
ultimately being like oh if I take from
this now I won't be able to have my
final picture yeah for health I will see
it grow and I'm like okay cool like this
is actually really helping me and it
kind of became a game because I'm like
well how much more money can I can I
raise oh really I'm at 2,000 bucks now
ooh now I want 2005 Hyundai yeah I think
turning it into a game is so it's great
too for me it was when I learned all
about like investing in the stock market
I really wanted to have enough money
should you learn that like how did that
come across I'm such a nerd like once I
start one book so I read the Rich Dad
Poor Dad and then it's all about using
your money to have it work for you and
creating multiple streams of passive
income that's how all rich people stay
rich and keep getting richer is they
have leverage they have money working
for them and they have people working
for them so to create anybody can create
that sort of leverage but you have to
know how and that's the one thing that
they don't pass down so in the book his
rich dad taught him how to leverage his
money and it's like investing and
businesses are the way that you leverage
your money and so I really wanted to
learn how I'm invest so then I read the
book we roll not rule number one by a
fill down which i think is kind of
outdated now but it used warren buffett
strategies to invest in the stock market
and you have to have kind of a pile to
start and that's what that was my
ultimate goal and then playing with that
and like seeing money grow and like
seeing how money can grow other money
that didn't even exist before is so fun
once you start getting into it but
unfortunately you're never taught that
yeah you're definitely a nerd Jess how
about for you how was your intro to - I
guess just saving I never really had a
savings I still don't
oh so I do have a degree you know
related to money but I'm in accounting
not really finance finance I think is a
lot more focused on personal wealth and
growth of that kind of thing mine's just
my experience is mostly with accounting
and auditing so don't look at me for
finance you're like give me your money
[ __ ] money just gonna critique how you
spent your money that's it but I you
know personally I had a really bad
upbringing with money neither of my
parents were good with money we didn't
know anything we were always in debt
always poor always like one penny away
from getting kicked out so I never
learned anything as a child and then I
continued to make like the kind of the
same bad mistakes that my parents did
with money as I got older and what it
would is sometimes so like getting a
credit card at 18 that for some reason
back in like 2005 they were giving 18
year olds like $5,000 credit yeah that
was me baby those B to 5000 my first car
was a thousand yeah I don't know how I
got so much right away but yes and then
so I just spent all that and had no way
to pay it back like I eventually had to
get that settled
so that being dragged on forever and
then finally I called them and I was
like can I just settle for like 600
bucks and then it just looked bad on my
credit for a little while yeah how did
you think a credit card worked no I knew
how it worked but I just didn't think
about the consequences I was like I mean
I'll pay like 20 bucks every month it'll
be fine you know the minimum balance
yeah like that's a mountain of debt for
you is you're basically paying interest
yeah you're just paying interesting
you're never paying down the principal
or how it worked though cuz I I knew the
basics I got something similar I got out
of five thousand it was a Capital One I
got it in the mail and I'm like hold
[ __ ] five thousand bucks to like an 89th
role you're 19 year long like on Vulcan
brooch um in a under I kind of
understood how it happened like okay
they're lending you this money and then
you have to pay back what you use you
know I didn't even grasp that I was
getting like this interest charged like
how did you figure all that out um I
don't know I just felt like everyone
knew that well that's just oh man it's
the most basic thing like there's
interest on a credit card like I know
maybe because like we were always in
debt because we were always getting like
reamed up the ass with interest like
being like super high yeah like having
low credit or a bad credit score it
means you're always going to have like
over 18 percent interest
even the most basic of loans car loans
everything that's another thing - my dad
made a series of like really bad car
purchases so we were so upside down on
vehicle purchases that what is upside
down mean so it means you the car is
worth less than what you owe okay so
it's kind of like you have this
worthless car but you owe like so much
money oh wow a lot of poor people get
stuck into this trap or they're like I
really need a car but maybe I don't
necessarily want one that might break
down in two weeks so I need to go to a
dealer and like actually get a car
that's gonna work for me you know like
it may be only a five year old car
instead of like a ten year old junker
for a thousand dollars so because you
want to still feel like you have a
reliable car you go to a car dealership
and then they wind up selling you
something for way more than it's worth
and because your credit is so bad you
get trapped in that so my dad did that
and then like he gave me the car after
he was kind of done with it I was like
going off to college so he gave me the
car so I inherited this upside-down car
do you know what it was it was a it was
a Chevy um I just want to picture you
what's the tiniest Chevrolet car like
okay never Buffet it or something I know
I do people you know finance is a boring
topic we could talk about the different
Chevy cars you're the teeny-tiny little
being of a cars it was a big piece of I
picture it now I got it had that thing
got broken into to so many times Dave
but yeah and then so when I went to
trade that car in for something better
that I wanted of course I rolled over
this horrible note into a new note and
got even worse into debt because I just
didn't care I was like oh I want a nicer
car probably like 20 okay 20 or
something and mind you I'm still just
starting college then so I had still no
financial knowledge whatsoever just poor
people mentality yeah so I rolled that
car into a new car well it was like it
may be a two-year old car like I got a
Nissan Altima and I was like yeah rich
now I've got my whip yeah and then that
thing carried over into the next car
that I got like I rolled over debt for
so many years on a car and then finally
what saved me was going to school for
accounting and auditing and then I got
into auditing and I got to audit car
dealerships
and then I my mind was like yeah I would
had a loan at like how I realized how
car sales happen yeah and like how
people get completely ripped off how you
can avoid getting ripped off I learned
so much I give me notes real quick so
let's see the first thing you have to
know is like you never just walk onto a
lot and take what they give you right
like I feel like even some people don't
know that they're like oh this is the
price and this yeah they don't know [ __ ]
people don't know to negotiate or they
say oh she always negotiate for a car oh
my gosh yes and then secondly people I
guess if your credits really bad the and
we're considered really bad below 700
honestly I don't
our dealership not just in life but at a
car dealership if you're below 700 the
the guys will make you feel like you
don't have options like they're gonna
bully ya that's really high you have to
know that they're gonna try to bull you
and they're gonna feed you a bunch of BS
why they make you sweat yeah because
guess what we're about to break yeah our
first wow this is perfect beautiful so
it's a help when you're buying your
first car we got our first sponsor and I
am so excited to tell you how not to
sweat and how to not sweat in a healthy
way oh that doesn't have aluminum in it
because no aluminum has been linked to
some serious health ramifications and if
you are using a non-organic non natural
deodorant it probably has aluminum in it
so let's get rid of that knock that out
of your shelf all of your toiletries and
pick up some native because native will
one it works it's it works all day it
lasts you put it all in the morning and
it lasts I like that it doesn't leave a
mark on any of my clothes that smells
delicious
smells so good is the cucumber mint one
it smells like a jolly rancher feel like
you could probably eat it don't quote me
but really it's organic so you probably
won't die yeah so doesn't leave any
stains or anything no they also have
over 8000 five-star reviews and have
been featured on TV and in print so oh I
have a famous yeah yeah it's ingredients
that you know so there's fewer simpler
ingredients so you know everything
that's in it watch read read some of
those ingredients tell me if you know
there's like coconut oil shea butter
cucumber experiment
bitter orange flower oil yes so it's not
like I put the pop elites and sodium
carbonate rates there's something for
everyone there's a wide variety of cents
for men and women men and women okay
pick up some for your boyfriend for your
man's coconut and vanilla is the most
popular size that's my personal favorite
there's also lavender and rose hue
cumber and mint eucalyptus and mint as
well as limited edition seasonal cents
there's also no risk to try it so if
you're like I don't know if this is for
me because I've been using some other
brand for a long time well first of all
you need to see a speech therapist about
your voice also
there's no risk to try it you get free
returns and exchanges in the USA so
subscribe and save seventeen percent you
could save two dollars per stick and
have native conveniently delivered to
your door every one two three or four
months and we have a special often offer
for our listeners for 20% off your first
purchase you can visit native deodorant
com
that's na tive de o dor a and t calm and
use promo code b tch during checkout
eh-eh without the I okay alright yes you
were a number of bullet point number
twos you know they try to make you sweat
how do you get a car without getting
ripped off Jess yeah man you just have
to walk in there with your balls hanging
low
whip them out on the desk and be like
just you just really can't listen to
what they these car dealers tell you a
lot of the times because they're gonna
be like oh sorry we can't do that we
can't do that and if you have the
confidence and if you understand how to
buy a car you're gonna read right
through that yeah but if you don't and
you've you feel bad about yourself
because you're like oh my credits are
like a you know 580 I don't know like I
really want this car they're gonna give
it to me is like a fear-based thinking
right you're gonna fall into a trap and
let these guys sell you something for
way too much money
yeah so once so let's talk about credit
because that I think is something that
would give you the confidence and
unfortunately since we're not taught
about it a lot of us [ __ ] it up super
early and then they use that to hold
over our heads to give us these bogus
deals all the time
so let's talk about credit you it sucks
because credit is bad if you get into
too much debt but you also need credit
in order to build credit so yeah
credit cards themselves are not bad it's
the abuse of credit cards that can get
yourself in a lot of trouble so starting
off with a credit card like you were
saying they'll give these 18 year-olds
$5,000 you you're 18 you're like I can
go shopping now and you don't really
think about how it's not just $20 a
month to pay it off you're gonna pay
that the rest of your life if you only
make minimum payments but you like
having that much money comes with a lot
of responsibilities so the bell with
spider-man right now I feel that comes
in spider-man or as a Batman nerds know
but you're talking about credit yeah I
said my mom always stressed how credit
was so important she never told me how
to go about how to build it to build and
to take care of your credit like yeah
just just I never knew the fundamental
things about credit I just knew credit
is important and if you [ __ ] it up
you're [ __ ]
it's so true that's what I knew so as
soon as I turn 18 my boyfriend at the
time he ended up helping me get a credit
card because immediately he knew as well
like you need to get a credit card as
soon as you can turn 18 and you have to
build a credit but at that time I'm like
well I don't have a job and he was like
don't worry I'll help you pay for the
for the credit card bill and so he ended
up using that card as if it was his card
cuz I didn't have a job so he ended up
[ __ ] me over with that credit card he
didn't pay for it
Wow busting him and so I ended up having
that credit card look really bad and on
my credit score and like moving forward
and throughout my life I started having
credit cards I had opened up credit
lines but I was really like I would not
spend what I did not have like I was
always so careful to make sure that if I
can't pay for this I and I'm not gonna
spend it especially from that first
experience with that first credit card
so ever since then though I've tried my
best to like never be late on a single
payment and now that I'm looking into
buying a home all that work was like
it's now paid off because you have a
massive credit score yeah better scores
off the charges
so I'm loving I even screenshot it all
three of my credit score little tips so
far loved it so much
yeah it's like like eight something so
I'm like dude this is an excellent yeah
yeah it's really excellent um for those
of you guys that don't know how credit
works just very basically said is okay
there's big banks and they say hey we're
gonna give you this loan and by credit I
mean credit score and they say hey you
need this loan okay we'll give you this
loan but they refer to your credit score
to see how reliable you are and how
risky you are to them so depending on
that number they can determine if you're
gonna be risky or not risky to send to
lend money to you so if your score is
below what is it 500 600 I think maybe
even 600 below 700 even oh really yeah
because below 700 is fair yeah so if it
is like maybe you're okay but you're not
gonna get the best interest okay so if
it's below 700 then that's when they
give you higher interest cuz you're a
bigger risk so for those that are like
zero APR which is annual percentage rate
that means that you probably have to
type score where it's like your track
record speaks for you where it's like
hey this person's really reliable the
chances of her or him paying me back are
gonna be highly you know it's crazy it
takes years and years and years to build
up to an 800 number because I've like I
said I've trying to big loans exactly
any loans you have to be on top of your
payments and not just being minimum like
it's and guess what not have you could
wreck it in three months yes I did in
one month I was I had excellent credit
and let me tell you you can destroy it
and then it takes you it takes another
eight years to build all the way back up
which is something that like I would
want people to know cuz I thought oh if
you like miss a few months no didn't lie
did you destroy it
okay so let's first talk about how to
build it because I know this can be
really overwhelming you're hearing like
a PR and you're hearing loans and all
this stuff so to build it the main
factors of your credit score are gonna
be the length of your credit so that's
why you want a card right away but then
it's also going to be your ratio of your
debt to what you call it that's an
income it's
it's your balance that 30% how much
lower first oh you're talking about
credit utilization yeah credit
utilization that's the term I was
looking for but that ratio of how much
is on your balance versus how much you
have to spend an example would be like
if if it's ten thousand that they lent
you in credit you want to spend ten
bucks yeah it's really that long when
you put a load 20 pretty yellow yeah and
so the best way to build your credit is
to get a credit card it doesn't even
have to be a big one it could be like a
five hundred dollar credit card every
time you go to the grocery store you
know you could pay for your groceries
but you put it on the card instead yeah
home immediately and you pay it off so
this makes it look like you are using
the credit that they're giving you and
you're very trustworthy with the credit
you're not letting a big balance add up
and sit there yeah that's a big one
because I didn't know like I would just
use my debit card for everything so so
scared of credit yeah but that's the
biggest thing you have to use the credit
yeah for them to see that you actually
have like a track you need history yeah
it's like yeah you're building that
trust with all these big corporations
that are gonna lend you money in the
future so the third thing would be
on-time payments so you got age the
balance and how your track record with
on-time payments is as long as you're
doing that for years
then you owe and like having a couple
accounts open as long as you're doing
that you're gonna build some really
solid credit like having a car payment
and paying those off on time those are
really big lines of credit that you're
paying off on time having a mortgage all
of that stuff you doing loans as part of
student loans yeah and a pro tip here
that didn't exist in my term because now
cuz you're and we just didn't trust the
internet because I was just like in the
beginning of the internet arrows when
internet was invented that's what Google
was that's wing geo was yeah it was
asked Jeeves before being yeah and you
like type in like I don't know how do
they make cereal and there was only like
five websites and you ask use was huge
because before then you couldn't ask
questions you had the only putting
keywords you weren't allowed to like
form a sentence yeah that's how old I am
yeah but now with this generation you
guys have no excuse not to pay your [ __ ]
on time you just have automatic yes
just ever write a check yeah okay the
Billick yeah I remember the first time I
lived alone in my first apartment I was
like okay I'm a grown-up now I get to
see like once a month like the grown-ups
I always sit down with their checkbook I
actually did that like once or twice
where I actually wrote a check for each
of my bills and I mailed it in I'm such
a grown-up there was online pain yeah
yeah you're all young I'm gonna do it
the way I saw the adults do it okay yeah
so I understand it credit queso after
building that like TIF said it takes
like eight years to build and I did that
and I was so proud of my credit score
because I had been taught at an early
age to do that and all that but then my
boyfriend and I went through a breakup
and we had shared the apartment oh and I
couldn't afford to pay the rent on my
own and pay all the other bills cuz they
use your credit for the apartment no
work but okay I couldn't afford to pay
my my rent so I used my credit card to
pay the rent to get cash advances and to
pay the rent and to me I was high
interest its temporary
yeah I was like all the cash advance for
those so for those that don't know you
can use your credit card and some of the
accounts will come with credit card
checks yeah and you can write a check to
yourself in cash that's like a credit
card advances what they call it it comes
with higher interest but you get cash
right away and so that's a trap that a
lot of poor people yep or people that
weren't trained and money fall into
because they're like oh I can get cash
right away I'll just I'll just borrow
you about a matter ya worry about it
later
now why those check into cash places are
yes yes and they screw people over when
they take a percentage oh yeah yeah but
when you're hard on cash yeah you know
so in my mind I was like this is really
temporary I plan on making more money
really soon so I'm gonna pay this back
and that just took longer than expected
and I actually it got to the point where
creditors were calling me every day cuz
they wanted me to pay the bill and I
actually had a heart-to-heart with the
creditor and I was like my boyfriend
just broke up with me all this stuff
happened I know it's your job to collect
money
I understand that completely i I know
you're just telling me what you need to
tell me and I just need you to know that
I hear you I want to pay you back as
soon as possible it's not happening
right now and I can't foresee it
happening for at least another six
months and they actually gave me a break
she like made made a note in my report
that was like like hard they don't call
her for six months how cute yeah yeah
she's like I just spoke up with my
boyfriend do I usually like understood
me it was it felt nice to be sympathized
with I don't think that works normally
it doesn't they don't give a [ __ ] yeah
well actually you can talk to just like
you could negotiate your car price yeah
you could negotiate a lot of things with
credit that I think people aren't aware
of like you say imaging though cuz I
settled it yeah hard bill for less than
what I owed and it stays on your credit
for awhile and it looks really bad well
you could negotiate that too
you can negotiate your own terms you can
say I want I'll settle with you guys if
you don't put this down to my credit you
put and you get written notice and you
don't say everybody yeah there's a lot
of tricks that you can do you you can
just make sure that they have the
written notice that they will not put it
in your report and then you give them
the money and that other thing but
they'll they'll take whatever they can
get so if you don't know to negotiate
they're not gonna let you know they're
not gonna do it right which is why this
is important to know and with building
your credit and with the car if you've
already if out you've already screwed up
your credit like for me I screwed up my
credit and I still wanted to buy a car
to build it back up again because
eventually I wanted to buy a house if
someone loves you very very much like
like TIFF like say you're friends with
TIFF and she loves you very very much
and she's like yo I think you're a
reliable person that just was in a hard
spot you can ask to be put on her line
of credit and that's what I do with my
dad the cosigner as a cosigner right and
and that helps you with your credit yeah
and even so I'm the one making all my
car payments but it's through my dad's
credit score so both of our scores are
going up every time I've you know it's
crazy so when I was assisting Bart
he had me go on like the so I could make
purchases for him yeah and that line of
credit not until now like I said
trying to buy a house I looked at my
credit reports and stuff that credit
line was still in my report where I'm
like it should be a good thing but he
had like a higher balance then I
normally have all my credit lines so
it's actually affecting my credit
negatively Oh so I had to call in and be
like hey this isn't my line of credit
and so it's a really really smart thing
to do is just to continues continuously
look at your credit report and see
what's on there because there were also
addresses that weren't mine and there
were other names like names that it was
like a different spelling of my actual
name so I had to like correct that stuff
too and I don't know like a lot of stuff
actually affects your credit and your
credit report yeah what the hell that's
a that's a good thing to point out a lot
of you guys may not be aware but you can
check your credit for free and without a
year yeah without it damaging anything
once a year and there's like free sites
that you can hit up I'm under to just
cuz I'd like to just see what the hell
is going on with my credit and just
whatever is tied to my social social
security number I use free credit report
comm and it gives me all three I mean it
is that an additional charge but I do
see the Experian the Transamerica I
think it's called Union yeah what I
actually did I went to each website and
they give it to you through that weapon
so like Experian TransUnion and Equifax
yeah
or you can go to Credit Karma because I
like using those ones in particular
because they tell you like how to read
your credit report they give you
different exercises there's like even
like if you have a goal like if you want
to buy a house in like five years or
whatever and it shows you if you're on
track to doing all that stuff and it
explains everything very basically for
you to understand and it doesn't use
crazy terminology where you're like what
the hell is this yeah live until I will
a negative the negative points again why
it went negative that's right and stuff
a lot of credit cards actually come with
credit trackers now so you don't even
need to use those websites like because
I know Capital One has credit but
anyways there's each ace has one too so
like I never even go to check my credit
like it's just always in an email
capital ones like nothing happened on
your credits you know this month like
everything's looking good I'm like cool
even mint has one - yeah yeah yeah so I
definitely great yeah they're really
good I would definitely take advantage
of that and then things that effect or
things that you need credit scores
or is like you said buying a car hmm a
house a house anything an apartment
mm-hmm
any sort of loan yeah your utility bills
like if you have a bad credit score and
you try to get like an electric bill set
up like when you move into a new place
and you're you know add your utilities
to your credit to make it look better
maybe you have bad credit they wind up
having to pay deposits on their electric
bills and stuff because their credit so
bad and we are gonna tell you how to
take care of that after we saw yeah so
Cara it's a vitamin and supplement
subscription which I've recently been
using and I love it so sorry
[Laughter]
so Cara it's so for me I wanted to get
back into a healthy routine so this was
definitely like it was a great start to
get me into like a boost of vitamins and
so what I did first is I took this
online quiz and it determines whether or
not like there are certain aspects of my
life that I would like to improve like
for example you could do like more iron
in your diet if your your doctor has
told you you need more iron they can
help you with that
it's super easy and convenient so they
deliver daily vitamin and supplement
packets all customized to your
recommendations based off of that quiz
and it's pretty cool because there are
packets they're actually a biodegradable
so you put in the compost so if you
don't feel guilty wasting plastic and it
is with your name it is so damn cute
yeah it has your name on it and I love
how they're in individual packets too
cuz you just throw it in your person
yeah like you know after in the morning
you're in a rush you just throw it in
there and super easy yeah I had the
grandma pill I had okay but I had that
pillowcase and I'm like dude this is so
obnoxious because sometimes I'm like
damn it I missed it but then like I said
that it comes individually packaged so I
don't forget about it yeah they also
have these really cool little packets
where you can it's like something to
dissolve on your tongue and they have
one tool it for your stress which I
picked stress and also energized so they
give you some energy and it just
dissolves in your mouth
and it takes really yummy they have
other ones too for like better sleep
what else yeah so stress yeah yeah
energy stress better sleep and so yeah
so I really love it I feel like you guys
should check it out too so for 25% off
your first care of order go to take care
of comm and enter b-tch that's 25% off
for your first care of order take care
of comm and enter code ET CH if you want
to know more about the compost packs
make sure to go to their website yeah if
you think that's a lot of packaging and
you're worried about if you if you want
to understand more info about how to use
them in a compostable way go to their
website
thanks George thanks George George keeps
keeps us out of legal battles no not
really I didn't realize how much
vitamins affected boo - yeah everything
yeah like you I was like crying all the
time and then I realized I was deficient
a lot of vitamins so yeah I was getting
migraines all the time and I realized I
was magnesium deficient Oh check that
out
how'd you check that out I went to a
doctor and he told me that I need to
take magnesium are we talking about we
were talking about how to fix that
credit or how to like you know help you
help yourself out well okay well what
about like savings cuz that's the thing
that even you're very interested in
talking about how how do you save well I
was talking about that in the beginning
which is you just have to really I think
having that goal in mind really helps
with staying disciplined because I think
discipline is really what you have to
have and whether you're motivated by
fear or you're motivated by a goal pick
with a one pick your poison but find
something that makes it that so that you
are disciplined enough to not draw from
that so true cuz just recently I decided
like Casey and I were like alright we
need to look at our finances and see
like all right we have our goal of
trying to get a house we also have a
goal of making sure we don't fall behind
on our taxes because now we have to do
like quarterly taxes which I've never
had to do before and adult you have to
pay your own taxes which sucks
yeah the money for I've been you have to
give it away not just adults but like in
the freelance in fact when you're a
self-employed because when you're an
employee they still take those tough
yeah and they end up getting a refund
check which is really nice but now I
have to do it myself so then that's a
goal of like how much to put away for
Texas every month and then how much to
put away for an emergency which is like
three months a bit of a minimum of your
salary that you should be saving and
putting away so it's like all these
little buckets of savings that have
really helped us save because with Casey
he also like so his parents were really
really awesome and trying to help him
get like his credit in in line and stuff
but they I don't I don't really know
like the extent of how much they
actually taught him about finances but
me being his wife it seems like he
doesn't really know a lot about his
finances so we're we're trying to work
on this together cuz I didn't have a lot
of education growing up and for him it
seems like they kind of just did it for
him so we're both learning together but
having those different piles of goals
have really helped us a lot
yeah and what I really want to emphasize
is I think that you should have your
savings and once you get good at at like
putting away money every month you
really should have part of that go into
a high interest either a higher interest
savings account you're looking market
yeah if you look at money rate calm
they'll show you who currently has the
highest interest account guard wallets
checking on savings on money what do you
Marcus yeah money market accounts all of
those on bonds all of that stuff they'll
show you who currently has the highest
interest rate you should put a big chunk
of that into something that's going to
give you interest and then the rest of
it you should either if that's not going
to a goal like travel you should figure
out like what you want to invest in long
term so that your money is making you
money that is what will grow that
savings pile because if you just have
savings that is not keeping up with
inflation yeah your your money sitting
there alone by its lonesome is is
degrading in value every single year so
you need to find something that keeps up
with inflation plus
maybe it gives you some yeah the way
that it kind of works is the higher the
interest the more the risk right so then
the easiest one that you can go to is
just your basic your basic savings which
is the interest that you're getting on
that which is the same interest that
we're talking about when it comes to
like that credit card interest it's it's
still like a percentage of something
that you either have to pay back or that
you're getting back so that's
interesting we're talking about with
savings I think right now for regular
savings you don't get any interest no if
you go to zero zero no if you go to a
big bank like Bank of America it's point
zero zero zero zero three or some [ __ ]
like that right but if you go I'm
telling you go to money right calm I've
been with a bank called Ally for like
ten years I get one point five percent
back when I first signed up but we got
five percent back that's when it was
like good yeah mm yeah I've met interest
high interest high interest savings
account yeah and they it's kind of cool
and Ally they let you separate different
accounts you can create as many as you
want and you can have ones for goals
like you're like this is my travel
savings and all of them give you the
same interest rate back and so when you
have a big sum of money in there like at
one point when I was saving for the
house we had a hundred thousand dollars
in there and I got like two thousand
dollars that year that was just extra
money and that's not a huge amount of
money yeah but it's money that I didn't
earn like I didn't work for that money
that's just extra money because it's the
same way that you're borrowing from
credit companies and you have to pay
back interest banks are borrowing from
you to hold your money and distribute it
the way that they want to distribute it
so they have to pay you back interest
that's how it should work but with big
banks like Bank of America they know
that you need them more than they need
you right so they don't have they don't
offer as high of an interest rate yeah
yeah for the house that we're putting
into right now I'm using the Amex
savings and that's a high interest I
forgot what the rate was but it's way
better than we're getting with Chase
yeah yeah yeah that's a good point
um and then the next tier after that
then you go into CDs but then that one
box in your money it does it amount of
time right it depends I mean that is a
higher yielding account or interest
account but it does lock it in so you
can have a one year they even look at
how they they
play the game with that and it's like I
forgot what the term is but the word
ladder is in it where they use it like
because there's like 5 years 10 years 15
years or whatever however long you do it
so like some people open it for like the
shorter amount of time and then they
have they'll like let it trickle into
the next one you know what I mean it's
kind of hard to explain but like if it
let's say I open one four five years
yeah and then once and then I open
another one for ten years so when this
five years is up then it goes into the
the ten year or like the next five year
one I forgot I'm butchering it you can
look this up or what's the point that
you're making point is that that's you
can play the system you can play a game
there where you can get the most
interest about holding all that money
for that amount of time oh cool or
getting some money out because I don't
expire so throughout time
oh there's games you can play with that
yeah yeah yeah you're absolutely right
I've even seen people um when I was
working in k-town like these these odd
your mom's like these older like
grandmas and stuff they knew how to milk
the system really really well so what
they would do this gets a little bit
more advanced but I mean it's not really
that event so they would get a credit
card with the zero APR for that year
then they would pull out the cash
advance like you mentioned so they get
money from that card don't have to pay
any interest on it for that entire year
then they started investing it super
risky cash advances don't give you that
with zero yeah it's just like using the
credit card oh well it is but or it was
like a really low or just like it no I
advise caution with these stories let me
just put my name on that you can get
creative that's all I know
oh I see what you're saying I know
another one which actually helped me out
a lot when I had I did have like a crazy
amount of debt at one point and it was
because I would I had credit cards that
were like 20% interest rate yeah I got
them like when I was really really young
those like nordstrom cards and those
Victoria Secret cards they screw you
have for sure they were a pro tip right
here so pro tip is okay you have a
really high interest credit card rate
you can look into a different credit
card where they give you a 0% about
trans balance transfer and then once you
transfer it over then you get ifer the
interest rate once you end up it one
time they solid eight your day yeah
exactly what year maybe like about a
year then then that's when they start
charging you their interest but usually
especially if you
had credit for so much time then by that
time that interest rate would be a lot
lower than the first credit card that
you had like 20% yeah that's a great to
capitalize on always getting the
introductory rate of exactly yeah going
to yours that's one of the things that
really [ __ ] me oh yeah I was getting
the old navy yeah secret and I hadn't
hit rest one and I worked at Express and
so I bought a bunch of [ __ ] on my own
credit card where I was working at
Express and then I just got the job and
then I didn't be I wasn't able to pay it
off oh yeah the life of a 19 year old no
but those those APRs on those cards but
you they give you like all these
incentives that as a young person you're
like oh I get $20 back if I spend $5,000
or 5% on this one purchase if I sign up
right now I like to bugs the last basic
thing that I think that people really
should know about our IRA accounts IRA
accounts you can open a I care
retirements yes but you can open a Roth
IRA and what it does is locally accusing
to me it's a way I know it's confusing
and that's why people don't do them or
know about them but it's really great
because you don't get taxed on that
money until you pull it out so you don't
have to pay taxes like or until you're
like 65 other investments yeah exactly
so your money is is able to grow and
appreciate and completely go past that
amount and but past the amount of taxes
that we'll be taking out and that's huge
because usually like your taxes get
taken out first and then money with
inflation your the value of that dollar
decreases but with this it's increasing
before you ever have to pay taxes I have
a similar with an IRA - yeah although in
the way that our IRAs work is like you
put that money in there and then you're
basically gonna use it towards the stock
market or towards the bond or towards a
trust it's just going through that
account rather than they're usually the
lowest you only have the lowest risk
start like a bond it's not like yeah
it's not like the regular stocks that
are like well it's like what market yeah
but it's like their bonds though you can
use it for bonds but I actually used
mine to pick my own stocks and invest in
whatever company I'm with it wasn't a
401k
no it was an IRA yeah was a Rasha
there's like so many different kind
a virus but my story with an IRA is that
I was working at a company and they they
had a like an IRA plan I forgot which
one it was but it's one where the
company could put in money and then you
can put a 401k no it's over 1k I was all
these sounds I know they are probably
there's like a thousand different types
of these things so don't work don't get
caught up on the on the specifics but so
Mike it wasn't a 401k but my company put
in some and I put in some and then I
left that company and I was still able
to put money into that IRA I just like
transferred it or whatever and then so
when I actually completely quit my job
that's that's a part of how I was able
to survive because I had put all this
pre-tax income into an IRA like while I
was working and then I cashed it out and
after I quit my job and I guess that was
my savings but I didn't really actually
have savings but the amount of money
that I made over the couple of years
that I was putting money into that
balanced out the time yeah so then I was
able to survive I only had like probably
less than ten thousand dollars but it
helped it helped me so much and it's
just like I almost didn't do that
because I was like no I want all of my
money everywhere I didn't want all of my
money but because I did that I actually
saved my ass yeah if your company is
offering that sort of deal call it a
companies do that definitely take it I
know it's like you lose out on that
money short term but you gain a lot more
in the laundry money yeah true because I
recently got a letter in the mail from
the hospital I worked in when I first
got into the hole of career over there I
haven't been working there for like four
years five years
and recently I got a letter saying like
hey we're transferring this account to
this account over here cuz I guess there
oh hell yeah that was like what I have
like five thousand dollars like I'm rich
yes I'm like hell yeah that's awesome
recently opened an IRA with their I CPA
and I'm like what I love all these
acronyms that IRA with a CPA yeah it's
crazy there's so much in this topic and
finance they they could all be split up
into different categories I hope that
these are just giving you the basics of
where to start if you're completely lost
but just forming good habits you know
putting away money for our savings
making sure you're getting interest on
that savings I don't have been more than
what you have yeah the biggest one is
Bart has this I'm gonna throw him on the
bus a little bit but he has this a
little bit where um he's depending on
money that he hasn't received yet mmm so
he'll say oh we're about to make this
some X amount so it'll be a cool if we
make this purchase and I'm like no you
can't mess with money you do not have
yeah so I would say to start you could
take a financial snapshot is what it's
called like go through everything you
have go through every source of income
that you have write it down write down
all of your debts everything you owe any
car payments that you're you're having
to make what your rent is all that find
out what your baseline is to survive for
like three months or just so you could
really see it on okay yeah yeah for you
concede three months or just even like
by the month like what do you need per
month to survive because then you'll
know how much padding that you're
working with right how much you could
put away maybe some of you can put away
fifty percent for a while when I was
working freelance I was putting away
fifty percent of my money because you
never know when your next job's gonna be
so I knew that thirty five percent of
that was gonna go to taxes and then
fifteen percent was gonna be savings but
I don't know if I'm what if for my five
months I don't get a job you know I'm
you're so disciplined stuff like that I
would have been like I'll think about
tomorrow tomorrow but forming those
habits and seeing how much you actually
need to survive really helped me be able
to put away that much because I was like
well actually I could survive off of
fifty percent based on these
calculations you know and it takes a
minute and a lot of people are lazy I
understand
but doing it is so helpful to forming
good habits and being able to see
exactly what your financial picture is
it's just the same as like if you wanted
to lose weight but you don't want to get
on the scale because it's too scary well
you don't know if you lost weight then
you don't know what your progress is you
can't see you can't form good habits you
can't know what exactly went wrong you
can't track anything if you don't know
what you're starting from yeah so figure
that out first figure out how much you
need to survive and then live below your
means yeah like be put away as much as
you can because that is taking care of
your ass later I always think of it that
way like I'm helping future Nikki's ass
yeah I think Nikki's going on so many
vacations you have her back much fun
yeah and that list that you're talking
about doesn't have to be really
complicated no just it's really basic
like in Java
yeah just write it down food and then
you just write down what I have and then
what's another one that you spend on
rent utilities figure out where you
could cut back like right so many
programs like Hulu Netflix Oh Amazon do
you really watch you know which ones do
you really use which ones improve your
quality of life what are the ones that
you could cut out like there's a lot you
can't cut out I was finding out I was
spending $200 a month at Starbucks no it
was like you know I have a coffee
machine gives you rewards though I'm
such a sucker for one thing I think
people also miss their they don't they
don't pay attention to and this and you
should add into that budget is just an
entertainment budget it doesn't have to
be lavish earn a treat yo'self budget
exactly but have that every month
because I mean you have friends you're
social person like you're gonna want to
go to the movies or whatever and if you
don't have that in the budget then
you're okay and it makes that a reward
yeah so as a reward for your good habits
like if I can save $50 this week I can
buy a $10 treat for myself I used to
when I was really broke but I still
wanted to treat myself because you keep
your person you need to live your life
right I would treat myself with like if
I could save X amount of money I could
buy a 99-cent nail polish for that month
and I got to like wear that color and
that whenever I saw my nails I was like
I did that money turn the [ __ ] you yeah
so just little rewards things that like
make your brain rewarded for forming
good habits I I kind of feel like we
should talk too what about the people
that right now maybe they're like 25 or
something they find themselves in a
complete debt hole they're so screwed
very common they don't know what to do
like what are the first steps we should
tell them because I found myself in that
position I was in a complete debt hole I
think it's what Nikki just said yeah
welling up with that list and seeing
where your money's actually going
yeah but like what do you do though okay
so like okay I am living above my means
yeah what's my next step you start you
getting [ __ ] up find a way to cut yep
find a way to make more money you can
either pick up another job pick maybe
you could do there's a lot of online
things you can do now like that you
could make just a little extra income
here and there
there's this one where you can take
surveys and give your opinion and I did
that I do that yeah it was such a waste
of time though basically like it all
work for like penny it is a lot of work
but when you're really broke like when
you're going out are you like interview
for jobs and you're not getting hired
it's like yo Luber you know if you're
really hustling you can look for ways to
make money you got right now it's so
easy with all these different apps like
we're mentioning like uber air test yeah
yeah these online there's so many
different ways mates like if I was 16
and today man yeah oh that's what I know
wow we've hit that key Bay you could
sell your clothes on Poshmark
sure there's just so many different ways
you can like make money quick you have a
freakin old-fashioned garage sale you
could make brownies and sell lemonade
you could just so many fighting just you
sitting there and looking at your
finances that's gonna uncover so many
things that you're like oh [ __ ] maybe I
shouldn't be eating out as much and I'm
gonna just make [ __ ] sandwiches all
day and if you already Fabio yes you're
living paycheck to paycheck you might
need to reconsider like living situation
your rent is too high that's the big
factor cars too much I almost lived that
baby moved back with my parents because
I thought that was what I was gonna have
to do luckily that month that I was like
I gotta move back with my parents
actually booked a commercial and like I
got a bunch of money that was like I
felt like the universe was like no keep
going but I was looking at every
situation like if I can't make more
money and I can't cut anything then I
have to make some sort of other drastic
improvement or getting extra roommates
or something getting a roommate yeah I
think one thing that you shouldn't be
too afraid of doing is if you're still
like 25 or something like go ahead and
strip go go be stripper it's everyone
does it would be like to just go ahead
and completely blow yourself up and like
just I mean not blow yourself up
literally but just like you can ruin
your credit like yourself up at is you
have to just completely it's almost like
bankruptcy right so like if you need to
like I don't talking about people who
are so in debt there's no
worried Oh like say you're you're so
concerned right about how much money you
owe you don't know how to get out of it
you don't know what you're gonna do
you're at your wits end it's like if
you're 25 your credit will be fine and
subbing oh my god seriously I did the
same [ __ ] I had like a 500 credits okay
I wanna listen it's fine if anyone wants
to ask me about it go ahead and you can
guess what happened you blew yourself up
and then what happened can like settle
all of your debts in some sort of way
get rid of everything you have like if
it completely ruins your credit and
you're like 25 it's fine cuz you'll be
fine by the time you're 30 like you can
just get a poison like oh you're so dead
all of these are names that are holding
you down like just say sorry apartment I
can't afford this apartment I gotta go
like start like you can settle all kinds
of things even if it temporarily ruins
your credit like you can free yourself I
think you say everything that you've
gotten into okay just find a way to just
let it go like strip yourself of it
don't worry it like your credit actually
repairs way than you think it does so
and even if you do have to declare
bankruptcy it stays on your credit in
years
yeah it's 70 years and um like that's
the next dream that's the most extreme
case and at seven years so if you're in
your young 20s yeah like you'll be fine
by 30 yeah just don't you so much
contracts and this and that like just
but just try not to get yourself there
in your first yeah but if you're already
there
you know what just let it go who cares
you'll fix it later good job Jess
there's a statute of limitations yeah
yeah is that is that it everybody all
right well cool thank you so much for
sitting go ahead and subscribe to us on
YouTube rate us on iTunes also check out
our Instagram and all that stuff and
thank you again to our wonderful
sponsors native and kariv for 20% off
your first purchase visit native
deodorant calm and use promo code b-tch
during checkout for 25% off your first
care of order go to take care of calm
and enter b tch
and thanks to everyone who wrote us
iTunes review so far if you haven't yet
could you and if you're watching this on
youtube hit like smash that like button
hammer drop a comments you know like dig
that Bell all that stuff all the good
stuff I don't even know if that does
anything for you but you know that's
doing me on and go to our individual
socials and just leave us those money
for flying money oh yes you know anymore
a little piggy okay and we'll see you
next time bye